hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the sour the shockingly
sour challenge I just came up about
myself because we came up with this idea
that we were gonna do the sour challenge
we got an assortment of stuff here that
is sour but then we're like that's
boring
we got muscle stimulators why wouldn't
we use them at the same time as this
yeah so we're doing to do exactly that
so anyway we've got a bunch of controls
here we got lemon add sour patch sour
skittles this [ __ ] here sour strips
these are all basically just yummy
candies but then we got warheads and you
may be wondering why we got the shot
glasses and you may be wondering why
we'll wire it up to shockers so we're
just gonna do these as a base level you
know no shock he's needed there we're
just gonna be like oh we know what's our
is we like Tyler and I really like sour
stuff wait does not even know anything
I'm pretty good with sours pretty good
exciting stuff so we're gonna
progressively go through we're going to
take a handful of each candy and we're
gonna pop them down we're gonna try not
to make a face and then when we get to
this we're gonna incremental II do one
more at a time and then increase the
voltage on our things one more that's
done it sound good wonderful wonderful
everybody ready ready let's do it what
are we starting with lemonade sour patch
okay the goal is to not make any face
yeah before is good enough there's four
of us four kids all kids for man
children trying to do what one
quote-unquote challenge three two one
bottoms up left hey mmm good sour back
boring [ __ ] get it out I've never
had lemon head I should remove means on
the issue should yeah lemon heads
lemon heads whatever damn hats Cheers
he's gone sour off you really not to her
yeah
sour boring [ __ ] down sour skittles
Twinkies queeny's month I spit in my
sack wha ha ha whoo ha ha I just read
these - for all you kids out there with
food allergies make sure you read
ingredients of the foods layered putting
in your mouth before you eat them this
product may contain trace nope good I
can't have these okay things [ __ ] these
things they're not sour anyway I tried
them before good thing I didn't eat them
that's why you read ingredients I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh hey so much bigger than
I thought they were three to one down
the hatch I'm not picture we've got the
sour powder oh yeah wait not having a
fun time
are you like Thank You scrying oh yeah I
hit me I hit me yeah that's pretty good
we could do the betting with those no
we're not gonna do the challenge with
that we got more warheads extreme
warheads yeah we turn on the mussels to
meal not yet not yet we're gonna do it
all right so we're gonna put these aside
for later for actual consumption cuz
those are good pick your poison I'm
gonna take one one get one for now grab
your shot glass so here's where things
get incredibly stupid uh we're gonna
continually raise the stakes by putting
one more warhead in our shot glass and
then turning the muscle stimulator on
both settings up one level not much I
feel a slight tingle all right three two
one down the hatch EpiPen at the ready
EpiPen is already cool here we go make
it really safe not yet bad another but
actually not even as bad as the strip's
description worse all right now to two
warheads muscle skins up one 104 army
I'm feeling a little more still nothing
severe I'm feeling okay occasionally my
risk and it twinkles and poisonous we
love it oh I'm starting to feel it
cheers Cheers why do you struggle so
much
because it's it's you know I've worked
but not keep out oh hi definitely okay
that he's got a good sour frayed not bad
not bad not bad
FF alright we got right now good oh you
got a good one ah got a really good hi
I'm a barely jiggling something with my
right hand Mar not that bad down the
house I'm afraid somebody's gonna have
to actually give us our shopping at some
point oh wait oh no we're only on level
three of ten
Hey yeah real novel for now right
yep for ah the things happening the
things just started music I haven't gone
to for you it's time
jingle hurry that's a jingle that's a
lot of it that's a lot of tickling and
applauding jingles better a Winkies
thank you uh Cheers
I don't know if I can put this in my
mouth Oh my body I can't bend my lips my
give me [ __ ] has two thumbs up robo
robo oh five warheads five muscles five
people is your mouth certain like hurt
hmm yeah well the thing about sour is
it's literally acid so the more you go
to the board it literally melts the
inside of your mouth it's very damaging
oh I'm feeling it right here
[Music]
hey upper shoulder who remember were
professionals
all right here we go then lay on the
hatch three two one klick East
ah okay I can't baby now I can't get my
arm
[Music]
oh no the legs are down to my love well
this might stop doing home so we're
going up to six now right wait put it in
ragged line back up cuz wait how did I
get one take a breath
oh okay okay okay okay okay okay it's
getting hard to have okay okay fine hand
coordination okay it hurts my body's
hurting you can tap out at any time I'm
not tapping out I'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yep yeah we're on six now
Kirk oh I'm going to six oh god I hate
that B okay one two three
ready to 4001 I've got it I'm gonna amp
it up oh okay okay okay okay I'm your
other angling so much I'm starting to
sweat very profusely do we have to go
Moo stuff ah I get to the part in sour
eating where I start sweating a lot and
talking like that but trouble starts to
blow up I Spit on myself I'm getting
lumps of my taste buds cells like in my
cheeks epithelial layer is five my mouth
it's starting to block off its funk the
night a better mistake
I didn't even turn it up oh hey mom your
mind turned off again oh you rotten Jess
you damn dirty API okay I'm going to
seven
I feel nothing but at the same time two
thumbs up remark okay I'm not gonna do
any we get this bad oh my god let me
shove that color
hey I don't think I can do it I'm gonna
you come on you eight I'm going for it
I'm going for eight that's a boy rattle
boy for the views win for the viewers
relate oh I'm sweating so much
I'm hardness left oh my mouth just hurts
so bad so bad every time hook these red
ones where you keep by the way just keep
picking a channel and I'll keep going
that's what I was trying to the order
actually did that it's dilson oh you
know this is terrible again don't do
this oh no I don't do a bad idea
you wrote that you think we're here
we're here to be stupid for you so you
don't have to be stupid come on up Bota
here we go
oh here we go
I can't pick it up oh my shut up oh [ __ ]
no this time oh my the shuttle to
martini does ever oh oh my gosh are they
on I feel like I'm gonna throw we can do
this I could do this but I might throw I
either know about eight we have known
about little one
I'm evil around everything earth
everything hurts and that danger right
now it's come down to a point of pride
more than it's a point of fun we're two
away we're so close we can do this No
can you breathe out sucks
I'm gonna shock to the guys I'm cute if
I do one more to our okay back this I
can't do this our okay wait steps out on
sour anymore I can't move my face all
those ready I'm at no I think I'm at
nine but I might have miscounted my nose
is starting to run there's so many plans
I'm not yours
what are they doing you my skin I feel
my tongue like falling apart my mouth
it's the most disgusting feeling uh I
love sour stuff so goddamn oh one more
fun one more okay one more I need help
getting them Oh what on I go to Tara I'm
gonna die that you're trying to push boy
[Applause]
Oh hashtag not worth it no more do think
I don't think they go honey turn it off
pulled up but oh this was horrible you
please don't do this
so bad this is the worst thing that I've
ever done from video so you want a lot
of subscribers kids huh you want to be a
youtuber huh do you know what we have
sacrificed is this what you want you
know what we have paid in blood and
sweat and tears and nostril lose are you
willing to make the sacrifice anyway
this was absolutely not worth it it's
gotta get dodo everyone is nothing
please for this egg taste nothing but
blood please for the sake of our own
suffering don't do that do not do not do
is really bad don't do it ignore the
fact that my nips are hard ignore that
it's not any indication of and your
hands are really sweaty and warm I came
really really that's the close end of
every goodbye don't start bleeding in
our mouth I would have kept going yes I
still love to taste the sour but the
blood is just I made the mistake of
thinking my cheeks were safe please
don't ever do that don't do that so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you thought this suffering was worth
it give it a lot evil like baby a
comment about how brave we are bird dog
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching
we're gonna go heal a lot and drink one
and drink a lot of water but either way
I had a good time
second time it was oh there's the rock
huh Oh bear that's so much blood I guess
they never live that's bad to look at
oh that's nothing very bad to look at so
anyways thank you everybody so much for
watching it as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye